we are with the current leader of the
Juniors section abhimani first of all
congratulations you came into this round
as the rating favorite you were playing
against a struggling player and you did
your job you did exactly what you were
supposed to do how are you feeling right
now as a new leader at least until the
last few games are over yeah it feels
feels good I definitely missed a lot of
chances in this tournament I've been
lucky as well a lot of times like for
example my game is Josiah was like dead
lost
then yesterday I missed Bishop C7 like
Bishop C7 is something I would find in
the Blitz game right I completely forgot
I missed the moment I was completely
focused on fixated on attacking on the
king side I've like forcing G6 to go H4
H5 but yeah other than that Bishop C7
that game was not too bad so yeah I had
a lot of time yesterday because he
doesn't have what are you upset about
that Miss Bishop to C7 because sometimes
you know you make this type of draws you
see that you had a clear win and then
you beat yourself a bit too much do you
do that yeah it was of course I was very
very angry at myself okay how could I
miss such a thing because especially
that after every single one of my games
where like if I made any mistakes I'll
set up the same position on the board
I'll try to find the better move like I
found Bishop C7 within like three
minutes yeah like two three minutes it
was very simple is your dad helping you
with that is yeah like the positions
during the game he puts it on our engine
and okay by the time I come out there's
like a list of lists of things
really okay because I think yeah if
it'll help me more than just like
checking oh this is what I missed okay
now the next game it'll be kind of it'll
be simpler for me to find those kind of
resources is it the me you do that
immediately after the game yes when you
go back to the room and then your dad
already has everything set up and yes
incredible yeah I mean I don't know what
to say to that that's uh dedication I
want to say and today you spotted the
moment the training has definitely paid
off because at this point you had this
G4 G5 but it wasn't clear I mean we were
looking at the engine the engine was
saying plus two plus three doesn't
really matter right the position is
still equal in terms of material and if
you don't find this G5 G4 G5 it's not
that clear either right yeah they should
come up to the conclusion of that that
is the decisive way because here once I
got this G4 G I think this main the
whole position is about my my Bishop on
D5
and his idea with Rook fd8 is somewhere
he wants to go 97 like I think instead
of did you can still go 97 directly
maybe what he forgot was that like At
first if I was considering Knight takes
E5 but I realized okay you can play D
Tech C5 and he kind of gets the he kind
of just takes on D5 yeah and this is
completely fine but 97 ideas I would go
back Bishop E3
so you know Bishop B3 I I'm never going
to give up this bishop without the light
Square Bishop yeah
so now my third is actually now G4 G5 is
a big threat
yeah
bishop and other than that like 95 in
some positions so maybe you go something
like I don't know H actually there was a
slight there were some interesting
moments before this like when I uh I
wanted to sack my queen with like Knight
takes E5 at some points it doesn't
really work okay so okay like with the
queen on d8 for example uh where was it
maybe somewhere around here yeah like
some around here like if night I was
going to I was calculating Knight takes
E5
like okay Bishop takes D1 Knight takes
D6 is winning for whites
yes I take another piece only someone
with checks and I take on D1 and I have
like the best three pieces that anyone
could imagine absolutely but the issue
with this is Knight takes E5 I think he
can play Knight xc5
Knight takes up six ticks Queen takes H5
Knight takes D3 Rook E3 now the
variation doesn't end because if Knight
takes B2 Rook H3 I give mate
so but the issue is rookie three he goes
to G6 now if I go Queen H6 Bishop G7 my
queen gets Force back because then he
takes on B2 oh yeah Bishop G5 is also
also an issue I think this one yeah
terrible
yeah crazy calculation but you did find
this G4 G5 and in fact after this uh the
position is almost hopeless actually
there was one more Point like uh after
Knight H4 Bishop
and a couple moves after H4 H5 this is a
critical moment to
because here like the first I would I
would have played like Rook A6 in a
couple seconds but then I noticed this
GTX H6 and queen G2 because Rook A6 this
position is much much better probably
even still winning because I have this
amazing Bishop on D5 you can it's
positionally you cannot exchange it you
cannot transfer this bishop to E6 yeah
unfortunately that's not how chess but
then I realized that actually I go GTX
H6 now this if Queen takes H4 Queen G2
and like in the game I just have way too
many threads because Queen H5 rookie 3
is game over because Queen H6 Rook H3
and queen takes G6
but another variation was GTX H6
and that this is the reason I spent like
10 minutes around here because now H5
Bishop H7 King F1 is the most natural
move uh Bishop Bishop G7
King E2
now Rook of it now the idea of black
setup is okay King in F5 if you get King
h8 F5 you might still be worse but
but maybe you can yeah yes uh King h8
and it I don't think it was take my idea
was Rook A7 here Rook eight whoa well
Bishop H6 and then okay seven because
actually yeah okay seven and these were
the two most I was calculated that's
actually quite uh beautiful and now okay
Queen H4 I have Rook G4 if you take it
Queen dear have Rook D7 Queen H4 and
book G4
oh that's nice and other than that
actually instead of this I was
calculating the reverse order if I go
Rook A7 first
oh
yes uh Queen takes A7
Bishop takes H6 I think here Black Goes
F5
Bishop takes G7 Queen takes G7 Rook
takes G7 King takes G7 now if I go Queen
G3 King H6 I might still be winning but
it's not as clear and if I go Queen E3
F4 maybe like most probably white still
has a win here but Queen is not clear
but yeah I think Bishop H6 first is very
important 700 signs nice critical moment
you spotted that one you figured
everything out I'll be money
congratulations you did what you had to
do you're going in the final round big
game tomorrow against Balaji who is
absolutely on fire how are you going to
approach that one are you going to play
a defensive game or or you don't want to
reveal your strategy well it's going to
be a fight tomorrow
because I think as you know like it
depends whatever happens in Arthur's
game I think he was probably going to
make a draw last I've checked I'm not
entirely sure
but yeah it's but still it has something
to be done that's awesome position with
Queens on the board but yeah this this
looks kind of dangerous for black but
yeah that's meantime at least like share
it first yeah I'll just I'll play I'll
play my best and we'll see what happens
no compromise guys questions for abhiman
our congratulations very very nice
variations that you're calculating the
Mishra and very good luck for tomorrow's
uh all-important game right I have maybe
just one question I'll remind you do you
uh tomorrow very important game
you know issues falling asleep because
those nerves are going to be you know
playing out or you are just it's gonna
be easy I'm gonna fall asleep play play
game tomorrow but yeah actually as of
now yeah this is a great question but as
of now me worrying isn't going to change
anything what I should best do is like I
should go to sleep as quickly as
possible then I should prepare normally
but yeah this I I'm going to try not to
think so much about it because whatever
happens on the board will happen me
worrying beforehand will not change
anything
very good Mishra very good good luck and
take us through our results as there